hi my name is Dave huh John Wayne
cancers to director of luck arrived at
John Wayne Cancer Institute in Santa
Monica California I've been doing
molecular oncology translational
research on human solid tumors for the
last 21 years our laboratory and our
department is strongly oriented towards
translational research related to
molecular biomarkers in solid tumors as
they relate into phase 3 and phase 2 us
and international clinical trials so
what I will do is give you a overview of
some of our key work i will use melanoma
as a model system and then i will add
some other cancer work that we out at
the end of the talk you can send your
questions during my [ __ ] so this is an
overall structure more like a functional
structure the genome in terms of
chromosome all the way down to DNA when
we're going to focus on today is
particularly on methylation aspect or in
other words epigenetics which has a very
significant influence on regulating gene
transcription more important in cancer
biology especially in the last five
years or disputes significantly exploded
so this just shows you a badge anomaly
and a generalized the chromosome we have
a new persone you can have different
ways in activating genes
and it is as we become understanding the
structure relation and the related
functional we see how genes turning on
and off is very complex but it gives us
alternative understanding of how genes
are actually turned on and off rather
than the traditional mutations or
deletions that we heavily focused on the
past epigenomics is basically the study
of heritable changes in phenotype or
gene expression caused by different
events there are many factors that can
modify epigenetic events that's in
itself a large topic but it meant that
could influence carcinogenesis or even
tumor progression or diet environment
age of the individual person growth and
cytokine cockers regulatory
methyltransferases which I'll discuss
later hormones I'll talk about the very
end and just plain DNA maintenance
replication events which occurred all
the time in every cell division but it
is also very critical that it is changes
events especially in the cancer
situation where it can be very abnormal
and then we relate too many
dysfunctional gene activity so this is a
model of metastasis many of you probably
know yeah primary tumor growth you can
spread through blood vessels you can
have circulate to ourselves Micro Mets
and lymph nodes and then can go to
different organs and so you have many
aspects of events happening and it's
very complex in itself and what I'll try
to show you is how epigenetics
particularly
can influence this raw so is an overall
factors for metastasis and you can have
the genome we well know which has
mutations lost copy number and variances
and we have epigenome which is
consistent micro RNA methylation and now
we know histones also play a significant
role and these all relate to the
regulation of transcript on which is
mrna so you can see that there are two
events major events that are happening
past we strongly focused on the genome
the cell and now we know that epigenome
probably plays equal or more influence
than especially in cancer than ever
before and so this is what our focus is
the transcript on a podium is essential
that we know there's significant changes
in tumor cells versus normal cells so
the gene regulation Epogen is often
focus on the CPG Island methylation
status in the gene promoter II does it
mean that's the only region it could be
outside the promoter region such as it
answers but it is the major topic I
focus on the other is micro RNA which is
an epigenetic factor can also regulate
gene transcription and other is
chromatone histone protein methylation
is set elation I won't be talking about
that today so this is just a schematic
or you got exon promoter region and
these lollipops are basically the cpg
islands or sites and if they're open
that means they're unmethylated where
red means they're methylated so
in a non methylated situation you would
have activation of the gene particularly
open reading frame and you'll get
transcription mrna the right hand side
after methylation you get
hypermethylated or you can see the
lollipops become methylated the red and
it turns off the gene and basically you
get no mrna transcription and what
causes this as we know one of the major
enzymes is the imminent release
transferees three a and B through Sam
activation of your methyl group and this
is what the methyl group looks like the
cytosine which is your basic pair and
you get methylated and you can see the
5-methylcytosine so this is a simplistic
way what happens when you get
5-methylcytosine activity now i'm going
to melanoma and to describe some of the
studies we have done but i will just
give you an overall melanoma as you
probably know his primary skin cancer
the most lethal pipe and most of the
melanomas that have found our primary
melanoma but then predominantly
expressed in the lymph node and you have
lymph node metastases and that's where
you get stage 3 a B and C it depends on
the level of involvement on the note
stage 3a be are often sent on lymph
nodes which we originally developed that
John Wayne Cancer Institute almost two
decades ago and changed the practice
early diagnosis of regional metastases
then you get distant meds in stage 4
which is the most lethal type of the
disease and once you have distant meds
it is very difficult to manage it is
very beautiful weather survival rate the
most important thing I want to emphasize
the melanoma lesion could be blessed in
a couple of
meters and it could be deadly lesions
that are like three to four millimeters
of their patients have a very very poor
survival rate in less than five years so
it's not like other carcinomas were one
centimeter tumor may not be that lethal
melanoma is an extremely aggressive
tumor to spread any site in the body
there is no preference and go to the
lung liver brain skin any order it's not
like other organs where there's often
preferential site or that it's related
to the desis do the drainage patterns
like colon to the liver so a lot of
describing this study that we published
several years ago these are melanoma
tumor related genes are a are beta 2 s
are a SF 1 a which we described in early
2000 Sox got a four with one with
inhibitory factor at PF on to it is a
regulator of plasma and we assess the
methylation pattern through the promoter
region which we identify a pcp gianna
and methylated sites and this just shows
you schematic it was done by master ray
then we look for methylated cpg island
sites as you can see that you have
yellow orange and red circles in the
diagrams under each team those are a CPG
on site and those that are highly
methylated they are yellow and those
that are not methylated at all a red you
can see next to it on the right hand
side the mRNA expression level
correlates is our SF 1 a-c me7 is highly
unmethylated in you can see mrna where
the others are very methylated and there
is no RV any transcription sucks one
yeah our controls are listed you you see
um see but very similar product for
socks one they're all highly methylated
and there's no transcript so this gives
you a sort out but most critical which
is being an issue in the past is to
identify actual CPG Island site that
really regulate mrna transcripts and in
order to do that you need to do these
kind of studies in profile and assessed
to determine what is the key regular
Terry CPG Island site so we did this to
profile all our genes and then we also
look at what you call non-coding genes
previously known as junk DNA or you have
sequences like mint which are multiple
cancer-related in especially min 1731 we
identified in melanoma and these can be
methylated or non methylated and they
can act as also an indicator of
progression and this is a correlation we
did with methylation status of the mint
loci versus the individual genes and you
can see there's some good correlation so
we use these as kind of a general broad
indicator of what the methylation status
of all the genes are that we were
assessing and one our study did show it
was when we call symp which is
methylated phenotype in melanoma pretty
simple and reasoning they're defined and
gastric with colon cancer or you get
high methylation as a progression factor
and symphony Mahna and this also was
found in melanoma however one does still
have to take this with caution because
you also get genes that also become
hypermethylated in other words in the
opposite direction which also but in
general
the ventilated tumors become sip and
become more progressively methylated as
it progresses so what we did is then we
looked in an array of stage three
tissues and as I previously indicated he
mp3 a be regulate methyl transferase
activity and this just shows you in a
study that the stage three and four and
much fire bmt 38 and be prepared to
stage want to do in other words we saw
the methyltransferase significantly
increases during tumor progression and
this just then we verified our tissue
microwave out stage three lymph node
metastases that were well clinically
annotated where the greater than five
years good survival no reoccurrence
versus poor those patients have died
within less than two years and you can
see someone staying and the
differentials from a B and C so one of
the factors that we found was that a
micro RNA was actually controlling the
methyltransferase so here we have two
epigenetic events that are working
together that are controlling and the
micro RNA 29 family has three members a
B and C on two or on chromosome 7 q and
the other is on one cube and we found
that they were very targeted to the dmt
3 a 3 prime yukio our region and while
we did is I showed you before this is
the pathway at my Garnock 29 3 was
actually down regulate EMT
three and as a result methylation of
mortar regional shut down so here show
that where the host has a way their
cells to regulate methylation is by d
mp3 transferases but it also has micro
RNA as a checkpoint and so we assess
this in melanoma to see what was this
relation hearing tumor progression and
here is an example where we saw my core
high 29 C or we did analysis of
different stages in SC in stage four
overall it was decreased compared to the
earlier stages which means when my
coordinate 29 C is decreased methylation
is increased and so where we did on the
tma we did a staining and assessment of
my chronic 29c cuddle and and the left
bigger you can see my micro RNA 29 C is
low you have a much cooler prognosis
versus i understanding that low Mike RNA
coding side see as more than 23 as you
can see on the far right loan amt 3b is
much better prognosis vs hi and
similarly we're high x coordinate 29c
versus low is much lower so what this
shows you how these two epigenetic
factors are honestly regulating
methylation but they have a sniff event
influence on disease-free survival and
overall survival so this is actually one
of the first time any group was ever
really shot of these two doctors
regularly ventilation without a very
significant relation to tumor
progression in a fairly long term
five-year follow-up so the next thing I
want to talk about
is the progression from identifying
these methylated markers so we have a
long history in our department he's
looking at circulating being a cell-free
DNA this is actually founded Surma
plasma and about over ten years ago we
were able to look at pacific methylated
DNA in serum that survived how i
survived before long pier time we don't
know and how to mow related genes
actually have a better survival rate
that normal based individuals samples
still a not but we suspect it's the way
that tumor cells are go under a pitocin
or necrosis and how they shed he may
uncut in other words not gone through
the abbot otic process to degrade
otherwise blood system will be
accessible but i'll talk about
methylated DNA how we utilize these
markers and so there's a different types
of CF DNA and we've demonstrated all
these microsatellite mutation and cpg
island hypermethylation and size in
terms of the integrity and they can be
used for detection of subclinical
disease or monetary progression so some
of the early trouser we did is by
chemotherapy where you do multiple
chemotherapy pre and post surgery is
part of an early program we did with
this with Steve all day now this is
starting to come more back into clinical
practice where you got multiple
regiments now to where you combine
surgery and new adjutant can more
effectively control aggressive disease
and here's example where we did pre
glee's to predict overall outcome in
stage four patients and show that appear
methylated for RAB beta 2 or rsf one egg
you have a far worse prognosis versus if
you go
and i'm right inside here both of them
you can see methylated is much more poor
outcome first year versus those that
know so here's a way you could predict
this outcome by monitoring the serve
another more marketed game is estrogen
receptor it is found in melanoma in
early stages the man who does methylated
similar to breast cancer where estrogen
receptor-alpha is turned off by the
methylation process and this figure
shows you how progressive state and we
are able to convert this to blood assays
a we can show that knuckle ated is a far
for prognosis and non methylated and you
can see that so this is a marker
approach using natural methylation in a
as predictors of outcome it's a new
source of biomarkers if you find the
right ones and how specific they are so
another type of marker that we looked at
are called line was long and good first
nucleic elements they're scattered all
over the genome like el lunes repeat
sequences there non-coding however they
have a long history evolutionary lies
and they recently become more important
especially in solid tumors that they are
often inactivated in other words
hypermethylated in normal cells but in
tumor cells they become hypomethylated
in other words 91 is active in they are
believed to play sniff again role in
genomic instability and also
translocation
all our studies we do we do laser
microdissection standard process so you
look at activity two more elements
rather than the normal tissue to get
real specificity so here's we show line
one index of unmethylated and you can
see it progresses significantly from
stage one all the way up to stage four
you see activities definite turn on and
then here's another molecule that we
looked at was aim one and gmail was
originally described in 6b 21 no one
really still found what it really
functions but we found that is
methylated significantly changes during
progression as you can see on the right
hand side that it becomes highly
methylated very progression and it may
be indicated still we have not what the
function is but this is an example so
what we did is this is a district court
get into that this is an example of
profiling how we do it what we do is we
develop a way you can look at overall
methylation by screening the whole
promoter region and sites next to the
CPG I the promoter region which we call
shores and then even further which are
further out and then we map out the
methylation levels overall and then what
the colors are is comparing me by
primary melanoma lymph node metastases
mbm as brain mets and other stage board
you can see the pattern and the shaded
areas is where the cpg island is the
most influence you can see the like the
brain meds are far more methylated men
than eli or the primary melanoma during
progression so you can see the
difference in mrs. re overall profile
the genes individual genes and so what
we did was combined stage one
hence these two patients and look at
these are primary tumors and looked at
whether how hyperventilation and
hypermethylation of line one
hypermethylation iphone methylase a1 and
or together how the fluids as you can
see if you were unmethylated a form and
line one methylated you know far better
prognosis versus those that game one is
methylated in light one is unlimited and
simple size is small but you gotta
remember these are primary tumors that
are only a few millimeters and these are
done off of help and section after
microdissection but what i want to
emphasize here is two different pathways
are going the methylated non-coding
versus the unmethylated methylation
conversion during progression of the
coding gene and so this tells you that
different events are occurring during
progression and both in non-coding and
coding and they're quite important or
wrong and here's another example where
we look at now stage for same way as you
can see those with unmethylated aim one
and methylated line 12 far better versus
those that are methylated anyone and
night long unmethylated so you can see
it quite relevant overall that these
events continually occurred during in
that stages of disease also we have me
focus a great deal in my lab on
epigenetic alterations of L&O
progression to the brain as I indicated
before a melanoma primary kid it's on
the skin but it can identify savant and
predominantly to the brain of entity the
law and generally longer the patient is
with it's a lymph node metastases even
those your secular of other organ map it
eventually
sir comes and brain metastases
eventually development and there is no
real pilot primary melanoma always goes
to lymph not it can go as we've shown
and if I pass right to the brain that's
what is known in love dances are on the
order and so this is an overall profile
where we did skin primary Mel lymph node
and Braman and overall whole genome
analysis and methylation progression you
can see clearly distinct the epigenetic
signature we're using it for 250 kb
array acid you can see significant
changes month not on over brain that's a
far right versus primary melanoma and
more to the left side this is a complex
diagram that shows the gases can go to
the brain quite frequently we show a
circus plot this is basically a right
hand top right hand corner it shows the
difference between lymph node which is
the yellow the inner part of the circle
versus the red of the outer and this is
the methylation level with red is highly
methylated and you can see and the outer
circle is basically the individual
chromosomes 12 22 and you can see how it
significantly because some of the
chromosome regions individual highly
methylated versus the lymph node this is
a good approach to demonstrate the
methylation progression on individual
colors and size underneath you can focus
on individual corazon it's a diagram
that shows how it changes from
development from a milano site all the
way to the melanoma and you can see how
they change for rest
Ras f1 a chromosome 3 be 21 you can see
how becomes more highly methylated 9
progression Ras f1a is one of the really
predominant gene that gets methylated in
melanoma is involved in microtubule
cytoskeleton migration events it is
following other cancers to like lung is
well known to be active and some in corn
country so one of the models have been
doing with Isaac which group is gonna be
they have a melanoma a human melanoma
they kept are transpiring it into new
advice and then we give about brain mets
and we took those re transplanted them
wrote to had clothes that would always
go to the brain Grizzles and always go
to the skin other organs and we were
able to use like he's three different
variants it was a very good model to
demonstrate a name we did methylation of
profiles and you can see and we were
able to separate out distinct among the
variance highly methylated versus less
methylated related to the individual
clones the ones that always metastasized
to the brain versus those that only go
to the skin so this was a very good
model to really assess if these are the
plots we conceded distinct subsets
clusters CPG Island sites they're
clearly distinct this is a more terrain
graph graph and it really showed you how
individual clone specific clusters of
methylation quite significantly among
the individual clones and comparison of
one of the original Parent clone which
is why the f are see versus other
columns that metastasize in this
distinctive next so this is the way how
we can analyze epigenetic events
occurring to specific organ concerts now
i will switch away from melanoma just
give you a brief of what we do other
analysis and this is in colon cancer and
business showed you is 2 overall view
where the left side is the histology
showing a normal be the adenoma benign
see is the cancer tissue and the right
where we develop equal a min diseases
dude thats related nominee coma is a
very highly sensitive pcr directed to a
specific mint site where we have cpg
island that is we know that's a
regulator methylation you can see the
enormous unmethylated and in the benign
it becomes unmethylated methylated
progresses this is an example we can
really pinpoint very small carriers from
parent section and really determine the
status of the methylation of a
particular site regime here's another
example where we can do the same where
we look at these are tissue query on the
right tmas but where we stained them for
colon cancer which is mlh1 which is a
stability factor regulator gene and pms
to as you can see we did the methylation
either by c q couple array
electrophoresis and you can see
unmethylated or its active and staining
on the top two right-hand side but then
we have methylated and decreased
significantly or no staining it off or
HML page and plc so here's another way
of showing how or we do is correlate
with the other which is actually quite
important to really demonstrate yeah to
have role to really show that the
unmethylated or methylated
events actually correlate to the
expression of the gene here's another
example where we looked at cox to which
is a very well-known inflammatory gene
and founded GI cancers particularly look
at primary gastric cancer here's another
example on the right we do coupler a
like a face as you can see it's
unmethylated the left hand side you can
see it's well expressed staining and
then just shows an overlarge this is
from the dutch study her name is van de
Velde where he shows the long famous
trial at d1 d2 resection regards to
lymph nodes it's a long follow-up of
over close to 15 years now we have these
specimens and we assess to suggest
whether methylated cox-2 or non
methylated as any event and you can see
from methylated which is team turning
off approach to a much better survival
than a non-network and traditionally
people if not i see riots see exhaustion
difficult to interpret and here we show
it can convert it to an en a methylated
you can see is as a real mechanism and
overall long-term survival you can see
the difference in the strong another
example that we've been doing in rectal
cancers where we look at retinoic acid
receptor methylation and other
transcription factors meant in 31 we
find and we looked at rectal cancer
particularly from the tme transit museum
director trial which is another large
dutch rectal study in which is basically
a pillar of many of the current trials
in terms of treatment of rectal cancer
and we looked at that and demonstrated
it was significant
his another study that we did on breast
cancer primer breast cancer where we get
methylation status and we're comparing
er- in your positive it is a state
recently published where we looked at
this large cord of patients that were on
hormone therapy and no other adjuvant
therapy and that we look at primary
tumor and we divided into no methylation
versus intermediate methylation vs hi
methylation as you can see the high
methylation to read the top right hand
corner of the worse overall outcome same
as on the bottom you can see the disease
concurrent and on the right hand side
overall survival and you can see is a
15-year follow-up on the study cities
are well documented here's an example
within maquette we started divided to ER
negative or positive in these tumors and
there are many curves there's a little
complex but basically the fatter stills
falls on the ER na end of the year
positive they're different but if you
look at the individual groups yeah on
the bottom left hand corner particular
you see are negative which is blue which
is normal you get a very good survival
rate your negative intermediate red line
which is for survival and then the Orang
is very cooler which is highly
methylated significantly different scalp
of my occurs sniffing difference you're
positive does the same thing so this is
a very in detail analysis of the yards
positive and negative phase over looking
at specific these methylated markers
that we could find to predict outcome
long-term so in summary overall I'm
giving you a synopsis of tumor
epigenetics if let's never control tumor
carcinogenesis
as well as tumor progression they
regulate gene transcription that's mrna
levels and can turn genes on and off
just as powerful as deletions and
mutations Bobby more common than other
events in especially in cancers since
they affect many genes it can be used as
diagnostic and prognostic markers as i
showed you both in tissue and as blood
as self free meaning it can be reversed
by drug I didn't show you 58 cited me
some of the newer drugs on the
methylation of pomona region but I see
now some of that he that inhibitors
which histones can also reverse so it's
very promising future so my studies are
supported by program project ro1 grants
and private foundations such as the
Adamson Medical Foundation thank you
very much there's any questions please
post
alright thank you very much for
listening any questions you can post and
hopefully I can address the future